we're six paragraphs in and it knows
about this point I've covered the first
sentence of this initial paragraph now
it's time to talk about this second
sentence of the lead even more
surprising to the research of us of the
fact that they spoke English and it
completely ignored the speaking English
part until it got to the part of the
news article where that comes in and now
it's talking about it
which is the kind of thing that these
kinds of systems would have real trouble
doing I've know journalists who can't
write that well if that ties into
something that I think is kind of
fundamental to the way that people think
about AI like we used to think that you
had to be really clever to be good at
chess and if you could play chess then
you were a real intelligence you had to
be and then we realized that like
playing chess to a superhuman level
doesn't require something that we would
call intelligence and it's slightly
unsettling to find that like writing
coherent and plausible news prose
apparently also doesn't require general
intelligence like if you just learn the
statistical relationships between words
but do that really really well
that seems to be enough I mean obviously
any journalist would would say that the
truth is kind of important in this as
well but yeah to make it sound plausible
you're absolutely right right yeah there
so there's there's definitely questions
about like directing this towards
producing a specific article that is
correct but just the generating of the
of the prose itself apparently requires
less like philosophical sophistication
than we thought then many thought anyway
I think 10 years ago people would have a
really hard time believing that
something that's just learning from data
and learning these relative
probabilities could produce something
this coherent you would expect it to
have all sorts of conditions and a
formula and an uncoded you would look at
this and say oh this must have like a
database of names and countries
locations and cities and everything else
because it's using that information but
it turns out all of that is already
represented in the data set because
we're talking about all these things
here's a recipe for some kind of
peppermint chocolate cake and it's got a
bunch of different completions so gay
can just spit these out arbitrarily so
you know those recipe blogs where like
you google the recipe for something and
you go to the blog and there's like
seven paragraphs of like my mother used
to make this for me back in our home in
Indiana
I always remember sitting out on the
porch with my dog he used to you know
the important thing is I had an onion on
my belt which was the style at the time
and and it's doing that it's like
talking about different bark stories
yeah just back story and um one
defendant was trying to make any of
these recipes yeah it's dangerous this
one so this is this is a recipe for
meringue cookies 1 and 3/4 cups butter
softened the cup of sugar and egg yolk 3
t of heavy critical T what unit is that
3 tons heavy cream that's usually a
lowercase T I don't know what it is 3
tons of heavy cream let's say three and
a half to four cups of flour pinch of
salt
peppermint Jojo topping which like I
have no idea what that is but peppermint
jo jo's is mentioned in the prompt so
one and a quarter cups powdered sugar a
cup of chopped pecans a half a cup
finely chopped mint leaves 1/2 cup
chopped fresh mint about a half sheet so
it's like it doesn't quite make sense
but it's right on the edge of making
sense like we have half a cup of chopped
mint leaves and then also half a cup of
chopped fresh mint all these potentially
cherry picked out of a huge number of
horrendous right yes so this is these
ones specifically or not so the unicorn
one and this is something that I like
and it's standard practice but I like
this the unicorn one it says they
specifically said right now we're gonna
make a sample for the paper they made 10
of them and they picked the one they
liked which was this one but for the
recipes here these are not cherry picked
at all that's why they're showing 6 they
just gone this is the first six that we
generated
and here they are and there so that
gives you a better idea of the general
quality of what it's putting out they're
all fairly sensible I like look at this
world right this one comes in and says I
do not substitute it with something else
blah blah and then like this I don't
know if that is right here's an image or
yeah please like this on Facebook and
then it goes on I found this really cute
card with cute little kittens on and
then as your samples cut off so it's
just like next post in the blog or you
know this is ygpt - is so cool to me
let's see the first thing they tested on
is a children's book test where this is
I think it's like a closed thing where
you just have it have a data set with
some children's books and then you like
remove one word and then the system has
to predict which of the words is the
correct like you give it you give it ten
words that it might be or something like
that and it has to pick what word fits
in this space so that's standard kind of
language model type task the one thing
that they did have to do is they had to
run analysis to check about overlap and
it turns out that one of the children's
books is the jungle book by Rudyard
Kipling which was actually in in its
entirety was in the data set that they
trained the thing on so he just knew
that one so then they threw that out
because I think that's not fair if
you've already seen the entire book
before and it's performance on that was
was good by the time they guts up to the
to the very large scale models its
scoring one is that eighty eighty nine
percent where humans tend to get like
ninety 90 to 93 percent
it's like nearly a human level for
guessing one missing word from a
sentence in a children's book pretty
good Lambada is designed to test
long-range dependencies which is what
I've been talking about a lot the task
is to predict the final word of
sentences which require at least 50
tokens of context for a human to
successfully predict it's like 50 words
is a pretty long sentence and so this
kind of long-term dependency thing is a
standard way of testing language models
and it ends up with an accuracy of 63
percent which is an improvement over
state of the art by four percent so it's
state of the art on Lambada without
being specifically trained on that just
running in general the owner grad
schemer I don't know if it's support if
you know event venal guard who knows
maybe it's somebody's name whatever this
is about resolving ambiguities which is
really especially important in
translation tasks and things like that
it's very easy for sentences to be
ambiguous in a way that makes
translating them very difficult or even
impossible and I have like I have an
example of this check this out
so consider a sentence like the chicken
didn't cross the road because it was too
black okay and then we can consider
different versions of this sentence
suppose that this is wide chicken didn't
cross the road because it was too wide
right that's like one possible
completion for this or you might say the
chicken didn't cross the road because it
was too scared another perfectly
sensible sentence then the question is
it in one of these it is referring to
the chicken and in one of them it is
referring to the road color for a third
and sure stormy stormy oh yeah alright
that's a good one so stormy means it is
actually neither of the things in the
sentence the other one that's fun is
something like busy right is it a busy
road or did the chicken just have better
things to do than crossing the road
we don't know I mean like I would say
probably the road but this could be a
children's book right we are running
this thing on children's books the
rabbit the rabbit was too busy it was
late for an important date why can't
that she can be busy so the point is
suppose we're trying to translate this
into a language the genders everything
as many languages do and maybe chicken
is like a is a masculine noun and Road
is a feminine noun and it has to know
what it's about right is this like is
this L or L or whatever so the idea of
this benchmark is measuring how well it
can resolve ambiguities because if this
says wide if you're trying to do
translation the old old-fashioned way
where you're like pausing trees and
looking things up in dictionaries and
stuff like that this kind of sentence is
the hell nightmare because you can't you
don't know I mean you just don't know
the information is not really present in
the text it's not present grammatically
it's present in your understanding of
the world and chickens and roads right
so translating this if this is it was
too wide and you translate it into
something which is the equivalent of the
English sentence the chicken cross the
road because the chicken was too wide
you've screwed up right that's a bad
translation but at the same time like
there's nothing in the sentence that
tells you that it shouldn't be right so
what you need to do is the same this the
thing that we've already seen that GPT 2
is super good at which is pulling in
knowledge of the world like knowing that
the University of La Paz is going to be
near the Andes or in the Andes right
that kind of thing it's going to know
that roads being wide is a thing much
more than chickens being wide is a thing
and so on and that like roads don't get
scared if it's scared crazy fearless so
again on this kind of thing it does very
well it beats the state of the art by a
lot you can see on this graph here so
the way that this graph is laid out by
the way this is the same in all of them
this is the size of the model they made
four different sizes of model and these
are like the same sizes that previous
language models were so they were like
make sense to compare them their
previous to the small ones they do worse
in a state of the art but then these
seven hundred sixty two million
parameter and the 1.5 billion parameter
significantly past stay after the art
they're getting like 70 percent so the
state of the art is the straight line
across right yes and the thing that is
also kind of fun about some of these
graphs is so some of them they're seven
six two million and the 1.5 billion end
up doing about as well as each other
which means you've like hit the limit of
I get maybe your data set or whatever
whereas in this one they're still growth
which means an even bigger model we
might expect to do even better maybe
reading comprehension this is another
thing you have some text you then you
have to answer questions about that text
right the thing that's fun is how do you
do this without modifying your model
that's just a generative model
this is where we start getting into
these us you know what I mean is the way
that GPT 2 works is you give it the
sequence of tokens and it gives you a
probability distribution for the next
token and so they're like type signature
of that is totally fine with if you're
trying to fill in a missing word or I
guess I don't know how they did it for
these for this test but you have to take
you have to take the challenge that
you're given and try and express it in
terms of this like predict the next word
type setup because otherwise you're sort
of cheating right the whole thing is
they're trying to go at this and not not
modify the system at all so for reading
comprehension the way they do it is they
give the thing bits to be comprehended
and then they give Q : a question a :
the correct answer to that question
newline Q : a new question they give
like three or four example questions and
then Q : the question they actually want
answered a : let it generate so they
sort of prime it I think we have some
examples of this so this is how they did
the question/answer thing they gave
these two paragraphs about the Olympic
Games to torch relay moving the Olympic
torch and I have some news story and
then a bunch of questions right question
what was the theme of the one world one
dream and so on and so on and then at
the end question and did they climb any
mountains and then a : generate me the
next word so they've used this the the
input text to kind of prime the model
now we're doing question-answer pairs
this is how it works right and the
interesting thing about this is it
actually ends up giving kind of a better
answer than that human generated answers
so the question did they climb any
mountains the responses they got from
humans were unknown yes yes and yes
because they do
plain mountains but gbg to dare answer
is Everest so
gbt twos answer is actually kind of
better than the humans the humans just
said yes they did and the machine
learning system has named the mountain
that they climbed so I don't know if
that's if that counts is not quite
understanding the question or if that
counts is actually providing a
high-quality answer it's up for debate
because it has this ability with
attention to do the long range it has to
look back past all of the previous
questions to the actual paragraph and
find the relevant information and it can
do it and it performs reasonably well at
that but the thing I love about that is
that they have to like come up with
tricks to get it to actually do the task
that they're trying to get it to do so
the summarization one is brilliant I
love the way they did this with the
summarization see if you can guess how
they did this right you want to get a
summary of a piece of text how do you
how do you get that given a huge data
set or edit content and what you do is
you write the whole long piece of text
and then you put like a new line and
then you put TL DR too long didn't read
in this data set there will be thousands
and thousands of examples of long pieces
of text followed by a short summary of
that text and in the middle is this
string TL DR I would love to have been
in the room when they thought of that so
yeah it's really really cool really
powerful technology I like it a lot so
an executable binary the net effect of
slotting that T diagram against here
slightly downwards is to show you that
the C you've written gets converted into
binary and the net output from this
process it produces out a program that
you probably store in a